digamos que [ __ ] el de aquí piensa que
es muy buen inversionista ok así que lo
que hace es o más bien tiene una idea y
dice mira voy a crear una corporación y
voy a juntar mucha gente para contribuir
contribuir con dinero y luego yo
administrar su dinero y luego tal vez
tome un poco de dinero para mí para que
pueda tal vez contratar analistas o
computadoras o tener una oficina así que
lo que hace es montar la corporación
digamos que monta a la corporación justo
aquí y digamos que tiene cuatro acciones
ok entonces estoy haciendo el número
realmente pequeño solo para hacer el
dibujo y las matemáticas fáciles esto no
sería realista normalmente son miles de
acciones verdad o incluso todavía más
pero digamos que tiene cuatro acciones y
todas ellas son propiedad de pitt
inicialmente sólo para simplificar la
explicación ok y pone 400 dólares en su
corporación ok
aquí están los 400 dólares así que otra
forma de pensarlo es que en vez de que
él ponga 400 dólares en su corporación
es que tiene cuatro acciones y cada una
vale 100 dólares
ok cada una 100 cada una de estas
acciones de por aquí y así que lo que
hace es que registra su corporación y
estoy hablando de un caso específico de
eeuu verdad pero hay muchos tipos de
organizaciones en otros países pero
bueno él registra esta organización de
aquí con la sec de eeuu gay la comisión
de valores y también se registra el
mismo enlace que aunque estos son sus
siglas en inglés por supuesto y mejor
aún registró una compañía administradora
que corre con la seca así que vamos a
llamarle [ __ ] inc es una corporación que
le empieza y que también registra con la
seca correcto y cuando registra con la
sec les dice bien en esta compañía de
aquí vamos a emitir más acciones para
que más gente contribuya y yo voy a
administrar este dinero de aquí y sólo
tomaré un porcentaje del total ok de los
activos bajo gestión a veces sólo verás
que se usa a bg eso significa activos
bajo gestión en su irá a bit inc cada
año por averiguar el mejor lugar para
invertir ese dinero y usualmente es del
orden del 1% a veces un poco menos a
veces un poco más
1 % el que va a tomar el dinero que va a
tomar [ __ ] justo ahora solo con 400
dólares eso nos daría 4 dólares por año
verdad pero como se registró con la secc
puede llamarse a sí mismo un fondo
mutualista y puede solicitar fondos del
público
ok así que es un fondo mutualista o
mutuo asaltado por todos los aros que la
secc le pone correcto así que puede
venderse como algún tipo de gran
administrador o qué sé yo no sabemos si
eso es cierto o no y también puede
solicitar fondos del público
así que del público del público y vamos
a ver en futuros vídeos que hay otros
fondos especialmente los fondos de
inversión libre en ese no pueden
anunciarse y no pueden tomar fondos del
público eso solo pueden tomar fondos de
ciertos tipos de inversionistas
sofisticados digamos y lo que pasa en el
fondo de pitt y que será un fondo mutuo
de inversión abierta que estamos
mostrando justo aquí y muchos de los
fondos mutualistas son así digamos que
digamos que leo viene le gusta la labor
de venta de pitt y dice quiero que [ __ ]
administre mi dinero también así que leo
va y le da 100 dólares y dice [ __ ] dame
una acción así que [ __ ] crea otra acción
de aquí
creado tracción aquí y se la da a leo
así que le obtiene su acción y en cambio
le da los 100 dólares para el fondo así
que ahora el fondo tiene 500 dólares ok
esto de aquí son otros 100 y ahora la
cuota anual de pitt va a ser de 1% de
todo esto o 5 dólares al año y si todo
esto crece digamos que todo esto se
duplica de 500 dólares digamos que se va
a 1000 entonces es 2 mil se reparten
esencialmente en esencialmente entre
estas cinco acciones ahora ok así que
todas las personas tendrían
esencialmente su dinero duplicado menos
los gastos de pitt en los siguientes
vídeos voy a detallar un poco más en las
mecánicas de los fondos mutualistas